après la déferlante omicron les
scientifiques se montre d'un optimisme
prudent les prochaines souche devrait
être moins virulente et en espagne et
bien le pays envisage même le passage
d'un état pandémique est un état
endémique autrement dit locaux vides
pourrait devenir une simple maladie
comme la grippe les explications sur
place de notre correspondante clémentine
lent avec une incidence de 2700 cas pour
100000 habitants ces deux dernières
semaines les chiffres du comité 19
restent alarmants en espagne et le pic
de la sixième vague ne semble même pas
encore passé selon les experts et
pourtant le gouvernement espagnol se
montre moins pessimiste qu'il ya
quelques mois il développe d'ailleurs un
nouveau protocole de surveillance du
coït 19 celui c'est moins méticuleux et
qui considèrent aura presque le virus
comme la grippe saisonnière alors les
détails de ce protocole ne sont pas
encore connues mais selon lui on ne
compterait plus le nombre exact de cas
ce serait des groupes de médecins et des
hôpitaux sentinelle qui se chargerait de
surveiller l'évolution du virus et puis
enfin on ne demanderait plus à faire un
test sans aucun symptôme alors même s'il
n'ya pas encore de date d'application
pour ce protocole les autorités
espagnoles se montre d'ores et déjà
assez optimiste est moins alarmiste
vis-à-vis du com et 19 en espagne comme
le premier ministre pedro sanchez dans
une interview donnée à la radio cadena
ser lâché toiture de mourèze l'académie
à mougins la situation n'est pas la même
qu'il y a un an et nous connaissons
mieux le virus la science connaît mieux
le virus en attendant de voir ce que
disent les rapports les plus concluants
sur le variant omicron qui est plus
contagieux mais paraît être plus léger
en ce qui concerne les symptômes je
pense donc que nous devons aller vers
une surveillance de l'évolution du coc
vide comme une maladie endémique d'une
pandémie que nous avons vécu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui d où la pandémie à quel look
emo juive l'une des raisons qui poussent
les autorités espagnoles à rester
optimistes malgré un taux de
contamination toujours élevé c'est
notamment la vaccination en espagne qui
selon eux réduit grandement la
probabilité de cas graves de kobe 19,8
espagnols sur dix sont complètement
vaccinés et plus de trois espagnols sur
dix ont reçu leur troisième injection
d'un autre côté le gouvernement a
annoncé sa volonté d'acheter plus de
350000 traitement pfizer pour soigner le
kobe un signe que le virus inquiète -
les autorités espagnoles qu'il ya
quelques mois